je m'appelle mariama ba tan si j'étais
mariée à un vieil homme
je n'étais qu'une enfant j'ai été amenée
avec les vaches et les chèvres mais je
ne savais pas que c'était madame j'ai
vécu avec mon mari pendant 21 ans
senna n'a rien on était bien dans ce
mariage sauf les enfants benbada
au total j'ai donné naissance à 44
enfants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous parlerons de tout sans langue de
bois
[Musique]
la sphère michel leclerc continue de
susciter l'émoi
les quatre policiers mis en cause dans
son passage à tabac ont été placés en
garde à vue et entendu par l'igpn déjà
suspendu à titre conservatoire le
ministre de l'intérieur a demandé
vocation emmanuel macron s'est dit pour
sa part très choqué après avoir visionné
les images
[Musique]
brrr exit à un accord reste possible
d'après le royaume uni même si le temps
presse le négociateur en chef de l'union
européenne se rend ce soir à londres
pour rencontrer son homologue
britannique
objectif reprendre les discussions sur
un accord commercial poste briques dit
entre l'union européenne et le royaume
uni
[Musique]
bien sûr que je le ferais donald trump
assure qu'il quittera la maison blanche
aussi le collège des grands électeurs
confirment la victoire de joe biden le
14 décembre
le président américain sortant qui
continue malgré tout de dénoncer une
fraude massive
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue si vous ne retrouvez
sur rtl france
emmanuel macron s'est dit très choqué
après avoir visionné le passage à tabac
d'un producteur de musique par les
membres des forces de l'ordre quatre
policiers ont été placés en garde à vue
et entendus par la police des polices
cet après midi trois d'entre eux pour
violences à caractère raciste
hier le ministre de l'intérieur a
demandé leur révocation
dès que les faits seront établis par la
justice
emily cook h mené par l'igpn une enquête
pour violences par personne dépositaire
de l'autorité publique et faux en
écriture publique vise désormais les
quatre policiers
il était à l'origine de la garde à vue
de michel est clair le producteur de
musique agressé faisait alors l'objet
d'une enquête pour violences et
rébellion
mais des images de vidéosurveillance ont
changé la donne publié par le site
d'information l'outsider elles ont fait
le tour des réseaux sociaux pendant de
longues minutes
on peut y voir michel est clair frappée
à de nombreuses reprises par plusieurs
membres des forces de l'ordre
ça a été tellement tellement difficile à
vivre
j'étais quand ils ont lancé lacrymogènes
j'étais au fond
j'essaie d'appeler mon avocat gc a
plaidé
plein de gens et j'ai même - voisins qui
entendaient may cry qui m'appelle qui me
dis qu'est ce qui se passe je suis
agressée et j'appelle la police mais
c'est la police qui est derrière enfin
c'est du n'importe quoi je peux même pas
vous dire ce que j'attends mais c'est
vrai que j'aimerais si jamais au moins
ça peut servir à ça d'ailleurs
j'aimerais que ça ne recommence plus
bien sûr pour personne les caméras ou
pas caméra ça devrait pas arriver sont
là pour nous protéger dit lapointe de
toute façon qu'ils font bien leur
travail
des images qui ont choqué l'opinion
publique
invité sur le plateau de france 2 le
ministre de l'intérieur a dû s'en
expliquer gérald darmanin a assuré que
les policiers serait révoquée
si les faits étaient établis ces images
elles sont
inqualifiable sont extrêmement
choquantes et dès que j'ai pris
connaissance de celle ci ce qui s'était
passé j'ai demandé la suspension de ces
policiers
et dès que les faits seront établis par
la justice puisqu'elle est saisie je
demanderai la révocation de ces
policiers ils ont sali l'uniforme de la
république ici encore une fois la
justice démontrent en effet ces faits
qui font peu de doute
alors oui nous devrons pu porter cet
uniforme ils seront révoqués la police
nationale emmanuel macron lui ne s'est
pas exprimé publiquement sur le sujet il
s'est en revanche entretenu avec le
ministre de l'intérieur en plein débat
sur la loi sécurité globale adoptée en
première lecture cette semaine par
l'assemblée nationale
cette affaire témoigne de l'importance
cruciale des images pour prouver la
réalité des violences policières mais
profondément choqué par cet acte
intolérable
toutes les conséquences doivent être
tirées de ces faits d'une exceptionnelle
gravité
l'état de droit n'est pas négociable
tout mon soutien à michel décidément on
voit à quel point les caméras sont
essentielles il ya quel point la loi
sécurité globale est désastreuse et doit
être combattue l'igpn cette comédie où
des policiers décident entre du sort des
policiers il faut la dissoudre et la
remplacer par une instance démocratique
vous refuser de parler de violences
policières
mais tant qu'il y aura des images on les
verra retirer la loi sécurité globale
une vidéo qui vient encore appuyer la
controverse autour de la loi sécurité
global autorisé par la justice
un nouveau rassemblement des opposants
au texte est prévu ce samedi
écoutez toujours à ce sujet lionel
perrin membre du comité contre les
violences policières à lyon
encore une fois on a une affaire de
violence policière dans laquelle les
images de vidéos alors là c'est andy
vidéosurveillance mais en fait c'est la
vidéosurveillance de la personne qui est
attaquée donc c'est des vidéos
personnelles qui prouve que ce que
disaient les policiers sur procès-verbal
s'avérer faut et on compte plus les cas
aujourd'hui en france et c'est le cas
notamment à lyon dans lé dossier qu'on
suit je pense à la sphère de cédric joue
via tout un tas d'affaires qui ont été
largement médiatisés ces derniers temps
où on est dans la même situation les
policiers donnent
des déclarations sur leurs procès
verbaux et dans leurs comptes rendus et
les vidéos ensuite viennent démontrer
qu'il disait était strictement faut
malheureusement la justice continue tu
semblais croire la parole des policiers
dans ce genre de cas comme une parole
d'évangile c'est bien pour ça que la
nécessité des images de de police en
pleine action est absolument nécessaire
pour que les enquêtes puissent être
ouverte d'abord on voit le cas avec l
affaire qui a été publiée hier
et puis cette ensuite mené avec
suffisamment d'éléments de preuve
après son adoption par l'assemblée
nationale est l'article 24 de la loi
sécurité globale va donc en être soumis
aux sénateurs le texte devait être
réécrit par une commission indépendante
extérieur au parlement c'est ce qu'a
annoncé le premier ministre hier mais
face à la fronde des parlementaires jean
castex est finalement revenu sur sa
décision
solène gaudin jean castex cède sous la
pression
les parlementaires ont mis les bouchées
doubles un appel téléphonique doublée
d'une lettre premier ministre richard
perron était vent debout contre l'
annonce d'une commission pour réécrire
l'article 24 du projet de loi sécurité
globale confiée à un organe extérieur
une telle mission constituerait une
atteinte aux missions du parlement qui
seuls écrits et votent la loi dans
l'intérêt d'un bon fonctionnement
démocratique
il importe que les procédures
constitutionnelles soient
scrupuleusement observé ce qui implique
de ne jamais empiéter sur les
prérogatives du parlement
le groupe la république en marche à
l'assemblée nationale n'avait pas manqué
non plus de faire part de son étonnement
par la voix de son président christophe
castaner l'ancien ministre de
l'intérieur bouillonnement aussi du côté
du sénat dans un communiqué gérard
larcher son président avait demandé à
matignon de renoncer c'est en totale
contradiction avec les droits du
parlement
si le premier ministre persiste est le
président du sénat considérerait les
travaux de cette commission comme nuls
et non avenus
ce texte fait décidément polémique
prévoyant des restrictions à la
diffusion d'image des forces de l'ordre
il a déclenché une vague d'indignation
notamment au sein de la presse française
ainsi que plusieurs manifestations ces
derniers jours malgré la marche arrière
du premier ministre ce vendredi
l'article 24 pourrait bien continuer à
faire parler de lui
une affaire rendue publique quelques
jours seulement après d'autres images
choquantes de l'aveu même du ministre de
l'intérieur est celle de l'évacuation
violente d'un camp de migrants place de
la république à paris
un policier se voir reprocher un croche
pied injustifiées à l'un d'entre eux
l'igpn a rendu son rapport la police des
polices souligne je cite un manquement
par un usage disproportionné de la force
gérald darmanin a annoncé que des
sanctions seraient prises contre la
jambe police mille places d'hébergement
pour les migrants c'est ce que demande
l'association utopia 56 associations des
deux exilés qui avait organisé ce
rassemblement lundi place de la
république
elles demandent des actes de la part des
responsables politiques et donc des
créations de places d'hébergement
d'urgence
utopia 56 menace de mener une nouvelle
action coup de poing demain sur leur
demande n'est pas entendue pour bernard
schmitt avocat au barreau de paris
spécialiste du droit des étrangers est
la demande de cette association est
largement réalisable avec la volonté des
pouvoirs publics
le tribunal a rendu son délibéré dans
les très médiatique affaire du
transpalette lors d'une manifestation de
gilet jaune en janvier 2019 un fenwick
sur lequel avaient pris place des
manifestants avait embouti la porte du
secrétariat d'état de benjamin griveaux
arte france s'est entretenu avec l'un
des prévenus reportage katia technique
tout le monde a en mémoire ces images
les faits s'étaient produits le 5
janvier 2019 lors d'une manifestation
autorisée des gilets jaunes et de
bellechasse à paris un chariot élévateur
avait forcé le portail du secrétariat
d'état de benjamin griveaux nancy un
porte parole du gouvernement avait dû
être exfiltré ils ont également des
fonds c'est la grise ont cassé deux
voitures est permis
et nous on a mis en sécurité l'ensemble
des personnels qu'ils étaient présents
inacceptable inadmissible moi ce que
j'espère c'est que les vidéos internes
permettront d'identifier ceux qui ont
été responsables qui seront conduits
devant la justice et sévèrement condamné
cinq personnes ont été traduites en
justice pour ces faits le procès a été
renvoyé plusieurs fois deux ans de
procédure qui ont éprouvé thomas hess
l'un des accusés il est simplement
brièvement monté sur le chariot
élévateur avant le choc
ce 5 janvier il essayait de fuir une
charge des forces de l'ordre on remonte
sur la route bellechasse et trompe sorin
fenwick
je vois des gens klaxonnent et du bon je
vais faire pareil je vais on va rigoler
un peu et je monte dessus j'achète mon
gilet jaune et coach turc arrivée il l'a
démarrée sujet bon avec avec l'effet de
foule et clament haut ce qu'on était bas
je suis monté dessus comme un enfant
qui monte sur un manège quoi et je
descends et d'un coup je vois il fait
une marche arrière et paf dedans une
personne sa famille c'est un mystère
jusqu'à on l'a appris sur les réseaux
sociaux la pression sur les médias
thomas n'a pas conduit ni abîmer de bien
mais il a pourtant été inculpés de vol
du chariot et de dégradations de l'hôtel
particulier ainsi que de deux agences
bancaires
je n'avais rien fait quoi un port est à
côté de filmer et de sauter comme un
enfant c'est sûr qu'au sein de pas la
casse moi je suis là pour manifester
chez manet jeu là pour manifester c'est
voilà je manifeste
j'écris dans la rue mais je suis pas là
pour casser des choses et en fait nous
on veut juste défendre notre bifteck à
la fin du mois on fait juste défendre
notre nos droits
le délibéré est tombé ce 27 novembre
deux prévenus sont relaxé de toutes les
charges
deux autres dont le conducteur sont
condamnés à 18 mois de prison dont une
partie avec sursis et l'autre
aménageable thomas écopé de 8 mois avec
sursis et doit payer de très lourd
dédommagement
les avocats des deux prévenus relaxés
satisfait dénoncent quant à eux
l'acharnement du parquet à poursuivre
leurs clients elle le savait et nous en
avions la preuve depuis le début elle
n'avait rien fait de plus que de filmer
les poursuites du parquet de paris et
est de ce point de vue là tout à fait
scandaleuse et répondait à une pression
de l'exécutif pour pour au final pour
suivre le maximum de personnes qui
étaient présents le jour de la
dégradation de la part du ministère
dès le début concernant mon client le
dossier était clairement dossier de
relaxe sauf que le parquet voulait
absolument poursuivre plusieurs
personnes ils ont poursuivi ce qu'ils
ont trouvé ce qu'ils étaient sur place
sans faire de distinction entre les
agissements de chacun en faisant une
poursuite globale et politique au moment
où ils ont été placés en garde à vue et
poursuivre en comparution immédiate on
était encore en plein dans le mouvement
des gilet jaune avec encore des
manifestations tous les week-ends et une
répression
des manifestations extrêmement forte
donc par la police mais en réalité sur
les instructions du parquet sur les
instructions notamment du parquet de
paris thomas heise compte faire appel
deux ans de procédure n'auront pas suffi
pour juger cette affaire de chariots
élévateurs vu par certains comme un
procès baudruche sachant que les auteurs
de dégradations dans les locaux du
secrétariat d'état à eux courent
toujours
nouvelle mobilisation des salariés de
bridgestone à l'appel de
l'intersyndicale ils étaient une
centaine à s'être rassemblés ce matin
devant l'usiné de pneumatiques à béthune
depuis l'annoncé de la fermeture du site
le 16 septembre c'est la première fois
que le conflit est porté à l'extérieur
de lusine à les salariés dénoncent la
tournure des échanges avec une direction
qui selon eux essaient de gagner du
temps est les détails sur place avec
notre reporter estelle charge
ils étaient plusieurs centaines de
salariés de l'usiné bridgestone à s'être
rassemblés ici une journée d'action pour
dénoncer la décision du groupe japonais
à qui appartient cette cuisine de la
ferme est le temps fort de cette journée
d'action c'était en fin de matinée des
salariés ont construit à des petites
croix en bois sur lesquels ils ont
indiqué leur numéro de matricule ils
sont allés en ils sont ensuite allés
elle est plantée sur un rond-point à une
centaine de mètres de leur usine
une façon pour eux de dénoncer à la mort
de leur emploi puisque cette usine et
bridgestone l emploi à 8 163 salariés
elle existe depuis 1961 c'est un peu un
monument ici à béthune c'est la plus
grosse cuisine de la région béthunoise
alors vous vous en doutez de nombreux
salariés ici ont consacré une grosse
partie de leur vie à cette usine à
l'image de pascal ou encore de daniel
respectivement 24 et à 39 ans de maison
ce qu'ils demandent c'est un peu de
reconnaissance je vous propose de les
écouter c'est pour faire voir que les
gens ils sont pas d'accord de ce qui se
passe surtout comment c'était annoncé
moi j'étais en repos donc j'ai reçu sa
part un coup de téléphone en disant que
ils vont fermer l'usiné qu on a tous été
surpris on penser que éventuellement et
on peut faire une restructuration mettre
des gens en préretraite ou structurel
usine quoi bien faire des départs
volontaires mais non c'était carrément
que possible c'est que du jour au
lendemain car mines et métaux ont fermé
pivot la villa le le souci c'est que les
négociations se passent très mal
notre président directeur général de
l'usiné il veut pas lâcher ne pas faire
le il veut pas donner l'équivalent de ce
que les gens ont pu produire dans cette
usine
on est mécontent de ce qui c'est ce qui
arrive maintenant on fait confiance à
l'intersyndicale et
qu'on essaie d'avoir le mieux qui peut
nous accompagner
je peut nous arriver puisque de toute
façon qu'on vous avait dit clairement
s'adapter voilà on a plus aucune
le seul moyen de pression qu'on a c'est
ça c'est de montrer qu'on est lent et
que on se laissera pas faire noter aussi
à que plusieurs élus locaux sont venus
apporter leur soutien aux salariés de
bridgestone c'est le cas par exemple
d'agréer d'adrian à 4 ans pour la france
a soumises ou encore de xavier bertrand
côté républicain et g - 1 avant la
première étape du deuxième déconfinement
à partir de demain les français pourront
de nouveau se rendre dans les magasins
une attestation sera cependant toujours
exigé pour se déplacer des placements
qui pourront se faire dans un rayon de
20 km est pour une durée de trois heures
à noter que les activités extra
scolaires seront à nouveau autorisée
tout comme les cérémonies religieuses
mais des cérémonies limité à 30
personnes par église l'épiscopat annonce
avoir déposé un recours au conseil
d'état ait pas de changement en revanche
pour les restaurants qui ne pourront pas
rouvrir avant le 20 janvier deux
collectif qui regroupe des grands noms
de la gastronomie et des centaines de
restaurateurs lance un cri d'alarmé sur
la menace de disparition qui plane sur
les acteurs du secteur dans une tribune
publiée par le figaro ils se disent
désespérés après six mois de fermeture
il demande au président de la république
de les recevoir pour trouver des
solutions pour pascal ranger dirigeants
et actionnaires de basri parisienne
l'état doit augmenter sensiblement son
aide à la profession aujourd'hui
l'établissement les gens ils sont prêts
à mourir à se suicider et créer plutôt
plus d'un million de chômeurs
on demande simplement 20% des jets
d'affaires
pas pour le mois décembre pour le mois
de mars pour le mois d'avril pour le
mois de mai et voilà on comprend très
bien ce qui se passe mais on ne peut pas
nous abandonner comme ça en disant à la
télévision à présidente et allonger la
sauce un ministre qui annonce une
deuxième chose et bercy en fin de compte
qui nous accorde que décembre sauf pour
les holdings 6 à binh dinh gut est
étonné plusieurs établissements vous
avez strictement rien donc aujourd'hui
on ne fait pas l'aumône
on demande de faire survivre aux
établissements pour cette pêche de crise
qui était compréhensible mais on ne peut
pas
rires à cause d'une indécision d'état de
terminaux agissements il faut que l'état
soit responsable de ce qu'ils font il
faut qu'ils assument ce qu'ils disent et
on demande seulement tout le monde
demande sur le petit moyen grand 20% du
chiffre d'affaires des périodes de
fermeture et autres manifestations
aujourd'hui à paris cette fois une
centaine de personnes se sont réunies
devant notre dame pour protester contre
la fermeture des urgences de l'hôtel
dieu
la direction générale de l'ap-hp a
confirmé il ya trois semaines la
fermeture de ce service du plus vieil
hôpital parisien
son démantèlement est censée permettre
de réaliser un projet immobilier et à la
transformation d'une partie du site en
établissement de soins ambulatoires et
de recherche pour les soigner en
mobiliser contre le projet cette
décision est inacceptable c'est quand
même un problème c'est à dire que on
manifeste avec des élus de la république
et le préfet mais enfin est-ce qu'on est
dans une démocratie et le préfet se
permet de verbaliser des gens qui sont
avec leurs élus légitimes au est
pourquoi nous étions dans la rue à ce
moment là parce qu il n'était pas prévu
qu'on soit dans la rue
les élus devaient visiter
l'établissement on doit les accompagner
en fait dans la cour de l'hôpital
sauf que martin hirsch le directeur
général avait fermé les grilles pour
nous comme pour les soignants c'est
incompréhensible
au moment du coc vide au moment où on a
plus que jamais besoin de recruter des
nouveaux soignants au contraire aux
fermes des services on laisse des lits
vides puisque j'ai pu visiter l'hôpital
il ya désormais des lits et des
brancards vite des couloirs déserts en
plein centre de paris
donc c'est inacceptable et aux côtés des
soignants demande la réouverture de ce
service d'urgence les urgences de
l'hôtel-dieu sens c'est le nerf le point
névralgique de l'hôtel-dieu le point
névralgique justement qui pourrait
donner la possibilité à martin hirsch de
pouvoir fermer les yeux à l'hôtel-dieu
au fur et à mesure parce que
l'hôtel-dieu canto par les urgences
quand on parle de points névralgiques
c'est l'accès principal laxey principal
à l'entrée de l'offre à l'offre de soins
brrr exit le temps presse puisque la
période de transition doit prendre fin
au 31 décembre au soir et l'absence
d'accord pourrait provoquer un nouveau
choc économique plutôt malvenue en temps
de crise sanitaire
pour l'éviter le négociateur en chef de
l'union européenne se rend ce soir à
londres pour reprendre les discussions
avec le royaume uni
parmi les enjeux de cet accord post
breakbeat la libre circulation des biens
et personnes entre gibraltar et
l'espagne les deux parties négocient
avec londres pour trouver un accord
commercial l'enclavé britannique dépend
à 100 % des importations pour alimenter
ses citoyens chaque jour 15 mille
espagnol traversent la frontière pour
travailler dans ce territoire
britannique
je pense qu'il n'est dans l'intérêt ni
du royaume uni ni de l'union européenne
ni de madrid ou de gibraltar de ne pas
avoir d'accord entre nous nous
travaillons tous extrêmement dur pour
parvenir à un accord
cela ne veut pas dire qu'un accord est
facile mais cela reste possible et cela
reste ce que nous souhaitons voir se
produire
nous travaillons en étroite
collaboration avec des fournisseurs en
dehors de gibraltar et des entreprises à
gibraltar pour nous assurer qu en cas de
besoin nous serions en mesure de
garantir l'approvisionnement de
gibraltar en produits alimentaires et en
tout autre matériel dont nous avons
besoin pour continuer à faire
fonctionner notre économie sans
effondrement économique est là avec ces
mecs là aux états unis donald trump
franchi un pas supplémentaire vers la
reconnaissance de sa défaite pour la
première fois le président américain
sortant a déclaré qu'il quittera la
maison blanche si la victoire de son
adversaire démocrate joe biden est
confirmée par le collège électoral
mes grands électeurs doivent en effet se
réunir le 14 décembre pour
officiellement
désigné le président des états unis
donald trump n'admet pas pour autant sa
défaite contre ce qu'ils continuent de
crier à la fraude massive si le collège
électoral élit le président biden
quitterez-vous la maison blanche jay and
il a bien sûr que je le ferais mais vous
le savez déjà mais je pense qu il se
passera beaucoup de choses d'ici au 20
janvier beaucoup de choses
une fraude massive a été découverte on
dirait un pays du tiers-monde
donald trump qui présentait ses voeux
aux forces armées à l'occasion de la
grande fête américaine de thanksgiving
une fête particulière cette année en
raison de l'épidémie de kobe de 19
chaque jour dans le pays le nombre de
nouveaux cas de contamination explose
grégoire doucet cette année la
traditionnelle parade de thanksgiving
dans les rues de new york a bien triste
allure habituellement des millions de
personnes se rassemblent pour célébrer
cet incontournable fête américaine dans
la deuxième ville du pays à los angeles
la solidarité est de mise
des distributions de repas chauds
s'organisent pour venir en aide aux plus
démunis
nous sommes prêts à mourir quatre mille
personnes mon équipe et moi avons
travaillé sans relâche pour faire en
sorte que ceux qui n'ont rien puisqu'en
même avoir un bon repas de thanksgiving
cette année après des mois de kovy 19 et
tous les problèmes de chômage c'est
agréable d'avoir un sentiment
d'appartenance à une communauté et la
façon dont il rassemble les volontaires
et organise tout cela cet éventail dead
cela vous fait sentir que vous valez
quelque chose
la nourriture qu'il nous donne là où je
vis dans un hôtel foyer et dégoûtantes
des sandwichs froids
je n'aime pas dire ça car je ne suis pas
une ingrate mais un repas chaud cela
vous réchauffe le coeur dans ma
communauté
on appelle ça la nourriture de l'âme un
moment particulier à l'occasion duquel
le futur président du pays joe biden
souhaité adresser un message ses
compatriotes
je sais que ce n'est pas la façon dont
beaucoup d'entre nous espérer passer nos
fêtes
nous savons que le simple fait de rester
chez soi est un cadeau pour nos
concitoyens américains
oui c'est un sacrifice personnel que
chacune de nos familles peut et doit
faire pour sauver la vie de quelqu'un
d'autre
un véritable crève coeur mais une
nécessité indéniable si l'on se fie aux
inquiétantes projection les etats unis
sont le pays le plus endeuillé sur la
planète déplorant plus de deux cent
soixante trois mille morts un bilan
colossal qui pourrait atteindre jusqu'à
321 mille victimes selon les centres de
prévention et de lutte contre les
maladies à l'échelle mondiale près d'un
décès sur cinq liés aux copies de 19 a
été enregistré à l'intérieur du
territoire américain
deuxième pays du monde le plus touché
par l'épidémie derrière les etats-unis
le brésil plus de cent soixante et onze
mille morts liés aux coville 19 le pays
redoutent une deuxième vague mais les
autorités n'envisagent pas pour autant
de mesures restrictives pierre pissavy
yvernault les hôpitaux se remplissent de
plus en plus au brésil avec près de cent
soixante et onze mille morts selon
l'université john hopkins
le pays est aujourd'hui l'un des plus
touchés au monde par l'épidémie
coronavirus depuis quelques jours le
nombre de cas positifs augmentent
drastiquement notamment dans les grandes
villes
selon ce médecin certains brésiliens ne
respecterait pas assez les gestes
barrière il y a eu une diminution une
grosse chute
aujourd'hui nous constatons à nouveau
une augmentation des hospitalisations du
fait de la flexibilisation des personnes
en général de la détente sur les soins
et l'utilisation du masque
la situation devient préoccupante selon
le journal extra 87 % des lits en
réanimation destiné aux patients
affectés sont désormais occupés à rio de
janeiro la deuxième ville du pays
la mégalopole connaît une hausse des
demandes d'hospitalisation de patients
atteints du coc vie 19 et le nombre de
morts liés
épidémie augmente je pensais passer le
réveillon du nouvel an avec toute ma
famille mais le virus m'a pris ça c'est
réel le virus est là et ce n'est pas une
blague
les gens doivent comprendre que ce n'est
pas une blague c'est vraiment mortel
jeudi le ministère brésilien de la santé
a confirmé la mort de 691 personnes en
moins de 24 heures
c'est donc un pays tout entier qui
s'inquiète des potentiels ravages d'une
deuxième vague ton président jr ball
sonar au très critiqué pour sa gestion
de l'épidémie n'a pour l'instant pas
évoqué la mise en place de mesures de
restriction c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de l'avoir suivi prochain point
sur l'actualité dans un peu plus d'une
demi heure restez avec nous sur rt
france
et y'a pas une façon plus une pauvre de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu en outre la peuplent
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi qui dès qu'on dit il
n'ya pas intervenir on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inusité gilet jaune c'était des
valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlement